es schneit wahnsinnig viel hallo meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einem weiteren kontakt hier auf
meinem kanal ich nehme das ganze jetzt
mal mit diesem mikrofon auf das ist das
was wir gerade gehört und jetzt seht ihr
das was ich hiermit höhere damit die man
also ich hab hier noch ein anderes
mikrofon ihr hängen damit ihr mann
keinen unterschied heute ich nehme das
ganze jetzt immer hier von meinem
schreibtisch aus einfach auf das ist für
mich die liga das ist da besser dass ich
dann eventuell dieses andere mikrofon
nehmen kann bis ich mir neues gekauft
hat was sich diese woche wahrscheinlich
sogar noch machen werde aber ich möchte
einfach nur gerne mal selber so der
unterschied höheren deswegen habe ich
das jetzt mal auch hier mit aufgenommen
ich hoffe da hört man unterschied und
ich hoffe auch dass das die beste es war
dann habe ich noch einen weiteren grund
dass da oben zurück zu geben aber das
soll nicht das thema an diesem kontakt
sein das thema ist ganz einfach dass
mein internet total rum schmeckt
irgendwie ich brauche jetzt mittlerweile
ist war ja mein internet war einmal für
einen tag weg und seitdem brauche ich
für einen upload fünf stunden davor habe
ich so zwei stunden gebraucht das ist
mega kaka einfach weil ich bin youtuber
und ich brauche schnelles internet und
ich kann nicht schnelles internet haben
weil diese blöde telekom nämlich besser
hinkriegt ich weiß nicht woran das liegt
aber sonst habe ich ja auch im letzten
kontakt also am letzten sonntag habe ich
ja gesagt dass ich in den kontakten in
den folgenden tagen immer etwas so in
der woche filmclubs in der woche film
werde und dass dann ans ende packte oder
immer mal so zwischendurch und dann
einfach so zeige was ich sogar die woche
gemacht habe und zwar hat dieser konter
gar kein richtiges thema weshalb fast
vergessen ich dachte entwickle ich
könnte diesmal gar nicht machen weil man
internet einfach viel zu schlecht war
aber ich habe jetzt einfach die zeit
genommen das ganze jetzt machen wir zu
machen mein hero lied gerade hoch das wo
ich das living metal dance wort kriege
die hero folge die heute gekommen ist
die findet ihr auf einem kanal und sonst
ist in dieser woche eigentlich gar nicht
so viel passiert ich habe bei klausuren
geschrieben deswegen war es ein bisschen
stressig und ich war viel zu hause und
habe gelernt allerdings war ich am
donnerstag mal einfach so draußen und da
war ja donnerstag oder mittwoch war
dieser blöde spuren dieser verstummt ich
hab gedacht ich stelle mich einfach nach
draußen und nehmen ein bisschen was für
euch aus hallo meine lieben freunde ich
bin gerade bei uns in der nähe von der
schule und habe mir gedacht jetzt
einfach mal ich habe gesagt dass in
kontakt immer so am ende so eine art
nicht wochen zusammen fasst man kommt
sondern sondern art so dass ich immer
mal so unter der woche irgendwas
aufnehme was ich dann halt so nachher am
ende packen und jetzt haben wir ganz
stumm frei bekommen
es ist echt so krass allerdings war das
licht einfällt
ich hoffe dem stimme ich hier wohnt
nicht in hamburg oder im norden gebaut
ich sage könnte mich überhaupt verstehen
blöden wetter hier
und das war halt echt nicht gespielt von
mir also der wind war echt mega heftig
wir hatten sturmfrei in unseren schulen
in nordrhein westfalen
ich wohne in nordrhein westfalen dann
irgendwie logisch dass ich dann auch
schon frei hatte und jedenfalls war
dieser sturm halt nicht zu krass der war
im norden richtig heftig dabei sturmflut
und alles bei uns war es allerdings so
dass der sturm hat wirklich
dementsprechend war das bäume umgefallen
sind das ein paar bauzäune bei uns die
nebenan umgefallen sind und dass ich
halt einfach fast weg geflogen werden
also ich bin halt wirklich so vom sturm
weggedrückt worden bin eine mehrere
meter zurückgegangen lieber mal und das
war halt schon echt krass dann am
freitag bin ich direkt nach der schule
da nach genau am freitag hatten wir auch
noch nachmittags unterricht frei weil
bei uns irgendwie lehrer elternsprechtag
oder irgendwie sowas war das ist nämlich
in der oberstufe bin davon nicht
betroffen hat allerdings trotzdem frei
und bin danach zu einem kumpel gefahren
zu christin kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
schon da haben wir dem ich schon mal ein
video gemacht auf meinem damaligen kanal
luca film der jetzt mein zweiter kanal
ist da kommen übrigens auch noch videos
das ist mein zweiter kanal jetzt
mittlerweile und da wollten wir dann
abends feiern gehen und dann waren wir
auch bei arminia gegen dynamo dresden zu
gucken als ich bei chris angekommen hat
echt so geschneit da das war so heftig
dass packe ich jetzt auch mal hirn aus
stand
es schneit war stellten hier gerade
durch bielefeld durchlaufen grafenberg
was chris berg mein ganzes handys soll
mit schnee und ich gleich auch hier wenn
ich mal die kapuze absätze in welcher
form ich habe ja gesagt ich hole das
erste handy raus wenn hier neuer schnee
kommt wenn hier mal schneit fenster dort
beweist gleich noch leiden ich habe ja
gesagt ich filme wenn der erste schnee
kommt und so habe ich es nun getan und
ich würde sagen wenn ich noch etwas
anderes dieser woche gefällt abhängig
dass hinten dran
ja das war halt echt mega heftig da es
war jetzt nicht so richtig heftiger
sturm und richtig heftigen flocken und
alles mögliche aber es war auf jeden
fall so dass es schnee während bei uns
kam nur im regen
und wenn ihr euch fragt was christoph
mich geworfen hat einfach so ein
schneeball mit wasser irgendwie auch
nicht geworfen das hat schon relativ
viel getan hat und danach habe ich ihn
auch dementsprechend anteil getreten
dann wollte ich eigentlich ein video mit
chris zusammen aufnehmen dass wir
einfach wieder irgendwas quatschen das
ja schon mal gemacht dann einfach über
irgendwas gequatscht über damals durch
unnötige leute in bus und bahn
wir wollten wieder so was in die
richtung machen was dann halt heute
hochgeladen hätte allerdings hatten wir
einfach keine zeit weil wir dann direkt
zum spiel mussten dann waren wir abends
noch feiern da habe ich übrigens auch
gefilmt als wir in dem space room bar
waren wir waren halt relativ betrunken
nicht man hört uns nicht richtig
allerdings habe ich danach noch mal was
aufgenommen wo wir wieder draußen waren
dass beides packe ich euch jetzt mal
eben dran
wie spät ist es wenn wir irgendwo
unterwegs sind jetzt zu mcdonald's die
busse überall sehen uns leute und ja das
war es auch schon
hast du noch etwas zu sagen ja also ich
würde mich noch mal bedanken für das
relativ positive feedback was ich
wirklich hab also ich hatte ja die
videos jetzt vorbei ja so war das dann
als wieder feiern waren und dann war mir
halt zu gegen 6 uhr wieder zu hause oder
gegen fünf wo ich weiß gar nicht ob dann
bei ihm geplant am nächsten tag wollten
wir es dann auch nicht aufnehmen weil
wir halt mega fertig waren damit wieder
nach hause gefahren das war dann der
samstag das war gestern
und dann war ich gestern noch bundesliga
gucken und ich hab auch noch gelernt
weil ich schreibe jetzt morgen und
übermorgen wieder klausur also montag
wirtschafts klausur und dienstags
deutsch lk klausur und das wird halt
wieder total heftig und danach werde ich
wieder so was schon viel in youtube
investieren hoffentlich an zeitweilig
danach erstmal keine klausuren schreiben
und dann wahrscheinlich auch ein
bisschen mehr im nächsten kontakt mich
besser vorbereiten und vielleicht kommt
da entweder eure kommentare werden
beantwortet also ihr könnt mir jetzt
fragen stellen wenn die frage in welche
fragen ob ich habe da kommentare
irgendwas zu meiner person dann schreibt
setzen der kommentare sein werde werde
ich das machen oder ich werde euch 20
dinge nennen die ich total mag das wenn
ich dann schon über die woche auf
schreiben also hat heute bis 24 uhr zeit
schreibt die kommentare vol was ihr
haben wollt dann werde ich das aus und
dann kommt das nächsten kontakt da kommt
dann vielleicht kein wochen
zusammenschnitt oder vielleicht am ende
gepackt und
dann werde ich dann hauptsächlich das
machen was ihr diesen kontakt mir hier
vorschlag also ich werde mich bemühen
die nächste woche einfach jeden tag
irgendwas zu filmen von mir egal wenn
ich auf dem fahrrad bin oder mein
fitnessstudio oder egal wo ich werde
mich bemühen irgendetwas zu filmen für
euch ja dass dann am ende zu packen dass
man so eine art wochenrückblick wird
wenn ich dann weniger zeit hab mir das
einfach nur sowas wo ich einfach meine
woche zusammenfasst und einfach da nicht
abkommen vor angeschlagen und hat
einfach so spontan ein bisschen
quatschen was ich so wie die woche lang
gemacht habe oder es wird ein wirklich
so dass ich mich dann mal vorbereitet
dass wenn ich ein tolles thema haben
dann nimmt dann infos zusammensuchen
zettel von schreiber und das dann
versuche lustig rüber zu bringen wenn
ich mir etwas vorbereitet und dann am
ende nochmal wochenrückblick oder das
wird wirklich nur ein wochenrückblick
irgendwie sowas wird dann immer am
sonntag jede woche kommen und wenn ihr
ideen habe bin ich echt offenen fragen
offen für ideen offen für kommentare
konstruktive fruchtbare kritik was
könnte ich jetzt noch retten
ach ja was ja auch noch wissen solltet
ist christmas kraft kommt so verdammt
nochmal unregelmäßig am anfang
eigentlich dena eingeplant das hätte
super geklappt dass dann jeder jeden
dritten tag eine folge gehabt hätte
allerdings sind jetzt nur kommen und ich
geworden weil der keine zeit mehr dafür
hat weil er auch schon zu viel im
ablaufplan drin hat und alles mögliche
deswegen machen es komme und ich jetzt
auch allein und das ist für mich halt
sehr viel stress jeden zweiten tag eine
folge zu bringen weil juli nimmt man
einfach so auf da kann man einfach so
aufnehmen da kann man schon immer mal
was bringt
aber bei christus kraft muss man sich
immer nach der anderen personen richten
und wir finden echt so wenig zeit ich
hoffe dass die nie dass diese woche
wieder normal christmas kraft kommen
kann weil kommen und ich werde morgen
aufnehmen am montag und dann hoffe ich
dass dienstag bis sonntag nochmal folgen
kommen aber ich kann echt nichts
versprechen es tut mir leid dass
christus kraft jedes jahr wieder ein
faillace
aber wir müssen halt in die zeit findet
gerade diese zeit vor weihnachten noch
mal die zeit richtig vier klausuren
geschrieben werden richtig stress ist
und naja allerdings war ich vielleicht
über weihnachten ski fahren und dann
werde ich mit meiner gopro die ich
hoffentlich zu weihnachten bekommen ich
gebe einfach schon davon aus dass sich
die kriege dann werde ich dann eventuell
ein paar sachen film und auch da will
ich dann im pool benutzt was alles also
um weihnachten rum und in den
winterferien kommen so geile konnte ich
richtig geile sache machen hab ich
richtig gute ideen und sonst würde ich
sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat dass
sich ein kleiner rückblick der woche mal
gemacht habe oder es überhaupt jetzt man
kontakt gekommen das würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freundin gerade positiv
oder negativ kommentare bitte unten rein
was sie für nächste woche haben wollte
und dann würde ich sagen ja